a trial of Edgar Rey killin who's
accused of the murder of three civil
rights workers in 1964 just outside
Philadelphia Mississippi the session
includes Fanny Lee Cheney mother of one
of the victims as well as the sister and
brother of mr. killing the trial is the
state of Mississippi's first ever
prosecution in the case
mr. Duncan you announced there in
chambers that you have probably the
testimony of one more witness have two
short witnesses are you ready to proceed
mr. Moran I noticed mr. McIntyre's not
here are you ready to proceed
bring in the jury good morning
good morning jury I'll not ask of you
have you followed my specific
instructions but generally have you
followed all of the instructions I've
had given you throughout the trial of
this case that the record show miss Rita
that all 17 have stated that they follow
the courts instructions the tourists
have announced they are ready to proceed
with the case so don't you may call your
witness
now see Scott
please court tell us your name please
Jay Cochran jr. mr. Cochran you
testified yesterday in this case correct
I did you testified that you were the
FBI agent who located the bodies of
Michael Schwerner James Chaney and
Andrew Goodman on the old jolly farm
owned by old and Burrage at the time is
that correct that's correct
was that location in the show but County
Mississippi it is I saw a young dog that
one any question mr. program up Chicago
stay on life
thank you call you next week you can
call miss Jeannie yeah for your collar
is chained
ah
miss Cheney would you be miss Cheney
would you be more comfortable standing
there rather than step up and having a
seat
would you rather all right
polish air ball around
you suddenly swear affirm that the
evidence you're about to give the court
in this case pending shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you God so here we
you state your name please my name is
Fanny Lee Jamie but I was a robber
before I married in Cheney thing um
Fanny Li FA any and ie that's right and
your last name is Phil dat anyway miss
Chaney I know we're not supposed to ask
a lady how she is but I don't think you
don't mind that question were you loved
one can you tell us how old you are miss
Jenny I made it to miss Chaney um witty
what do you live I live in New Jersey
now when did you move to New Jersey
oh but oh five three years ago I was
living in now Willis point that's in no
question namely there please pabich down
gerenian would he be reading you where
you live before well no I live here I
live here and testify I mean yeah and
65g he got killed in 64 and I live here
cause I couldn't wake no more nothing so
I live here with the New York and I
stayed there until about five years ago
and I moved to New Jersey
I see did you live in Meridian prior to
1965 I've been here all my life I was
born a lot like a kind miss Channing
did you have any children I hate by okay
um Ernie over here today yeah it - yeah
hey were they - my children should be
which boy stay right here my oldest
daughter my babies on what suppose your
baby son what's his name being chained
did you also have another son yeah but
James chain was my oldest son what y'all
call James we call him je je je
definitions name with James er now where
did je live
prior to his death well he lived with me
most of the time all the time when he
was in town how about in the spring say
of 1964 and spraying well he was he was
living down there with the father but
huh he made making them then he got with
them and they would stay at my house
sometime and make his place where he was
standing
you mean Mickey Schwerner yeah was he
working with Mickey Schwerner yeah and
did dog je go to Ohio at any time do er
did je go to Ohio sometime in 60 mmm he
went to Ohio
there you go with he won with me and
reader Mickey and readers Warner when
you remember about when that was that
they went up there oh well I don't think
I can't remember the date did ragel it
right date or nothing yes ma'am whoa um
how about when he returned you remember
when the address came to my house on the
Saturday afternoon for coming from up
there and they came in 8th when James
taking a meeting and 2 to the hectare
with me Mickey was named it so when you
say they came in on that Saturday was it
at Saturday afternoon
minor Wednesday afternoon um who always
was with je when they arrived at your
house uh making in Mickey and Andy and
when you say Andy uh who you talking
about
miss Warner son it's good my song Andy
Goodman mm-hmm um so they just got in
Ohio and came to your house name mm-hmm
um that was Saturday afternoon what what
did Jay you come back to your house
after they after he took them yeah he
come back and meet him sit up and talk
and talk until about two three o'clock
then with the big boys went to sleep and
then when I woke up like that often fix
burgers and eat brother and said I'm gon
think of making and N and we got some
books we're gonna take to the office and
then he left and he was really then was
sitting on the steps cry on the father
Jan but I would let him go with I told
him go to Sunday school and when James
come home daddy
he said he was gonna come back and we
were him and being him and just being
could go with Jay you know be around
with all leave but Jane I will come back
now you say je I mean I'm being how was
being when he's sitting on the front
step
oh where he was someone like about ten
and he yeah given by ten Coulson July
his first day in the maybe living years
old
oh did you say band wasn't wanting to go
would you eat that morning oh you
already described he wanted to go wooden
red Sun he's described I mean I mean je
promising see you wait until I get back
in you I take you with me Missy and you
never come back
tell me when um when when did you find
out that uh je wasn't coming back
there's mention of where would I find
that the Reverend poetry of don't work
owner for me
God's miss chain speak last answer uh
rubble folder lived on the corner from
and he came up about eight o'clock that
Sunday night and told me said we've been
trying to track the boys we found them
here and when we don't get getting the
road we don't he selling got two three
mo fellas with me and we gonna thing
sing I said I love what I want to go
with you he said no you stay here
cuz if he called you beat home so oh he
wind and my mom when he told me he said
we found no trace of he come and told me
trouble Pollard he said he didn't find
no trace of and that's when I know he
was list do you recall when the vehicle
was found I saw it on TV in the wolves
but
you could tell it how it was been he
despite it on TV that's the way he would
looked on the TV
what about do you recall when you were
notified about huh do you recall when
you were notified about the some bodies
being found mm-hmm mr. Wyden from the
Washington called me two or three times
and told me they had found a body but it
was a house is agree then he called me
again the next 2-3 days that they had
found two bodies and it was two student
from Jackson schools college in the city
one of them bought it was cut off and
one went o kk pants with those big
silver i told that one now would another
James because he didn't live with it he
didn't have that the way um after the
bodies were discovered as a result of
JD's work did you have any threats or
anything dude did you have any threats
as a result of JD's work hmm
no what I am the grace um but maybe you
didn't understand me did you have any
were you threatened or anything as a
result of oh yeah oh yeah I'm getting
phone calls people who passed by the
house a car full of white folks passing
by the house and throwing eggs on it and
they thought maybe they shot it if
they'd have been close to come to the
one I ring the other big day cause they
shot we're right on your driveway that
someone really didn't
hit the house what why did you have to
move Mississippi well I couldn't get a
job that no mo and nothing and they were
threatened me so bad me my little son
jacobean they told they were gonna put a
dynamite under the house blow blow us to
bits and everything and I better get on
away from them cuz I wasn't gonna be
that loan for their be but I'd be put in
a hole like James or how my approach
would yes it's you
this is my son I kept a picture hanging
up in my house
I smile or something James change
castle of the dependents you have an
objection to photograph it let it be
marked
miss Jania about how was jz1 this well
he dissed me to 21st birthday in me and
get killed in june he made his 21st
birthday and my and he got killed in
June his bone on remote dick going on
Memorial Day yeah I don't know oppose
this cross-examine yeah lady would you
come around sis miss Chaney from the
chair
all right for the state
what do you call next
stay dressed while you have for the
defendant
let the stur be retire to the jury room
I'll hear this motion out of your
presence panicked retreat the program
it's Brad miss McIntyre the jury has
been retired from the courtroom I'll
hear you motion may it please the court
at this time I'm asked this court to
enter a directed verdict in favor of the
defendant dismissing the case based on
the following issues the first issue I'm
going to address is the prior
transcribed testimony that was allowed
into evidence the first argument is that
Dakota I'll renew the argument that the
code of 1942 should prevail in this case
which did not allow this testimony into
evidence
secondly addressing this testimony it
was objected to when it was first tried
to be introduced on the fact that the
personnel was reading the transcript
never testified that the transcript that
they were reading was a true and correct
copy of the certified copy that counsel
had in the briefcase now after the first
two witnesses or the first two witnesses
testimony was read into the record
counsel then started asking his readers
to testify to the fact that they were
reading from a true and correct copy of
the transcript testimony but the first
two were not another issue on the prior
transcript testimony is the fact that it
was then objected to that there was no
proof of unavailability of the witness
the core in chambers on the record made
a ruling that they either had to have a
death certificate in an affidavit would
suffice
if the affiant was available the next
day witnesses put on the stand and
Elmore Dennis's testimony is being read
into the record objected five minutes
into the testimony and it was then found
out that we still hadn't made the proper
foundation to allow that testimony in
and there had been no ruling by this
court from your prior ruling and
sustaining my objection allowing this
testimony in the court then modified its
ruling at that point and allowed this
testimony in as long as we had a facts
milk copy of a death certificate of
though there was no a cetacean on it and
an affidavit but the affiant was not
available now we then started entering
more testimony the death certificate
came in counsel was allowed to
supplement and add the death
certificates as they came in which would
have no evidentiary value after the fact
of the ruling council in addresses the
court with the issue of there has been
no foundation laid showing that the
testimony that was read into the record
used against the defendant the
requirements are that there has to be a
showing that the defendant had the
opportunity to cross-examine that
witness in the prior trial that the
subject matter
was closely-related enough and lastly it
has to been shown that that testimony
was sworn to and there has been no
evidence to this point that the
testimony that was read into this record
was sworn testimony there's been nothing
that has showed that that testimony came
from a proceeding in which the defendant
had counsel and there has been nothing
in the record to show that the
subject-matter of that prior trial was
closely related to the subject matter in
this trial so there's absolutely no
foundation for allowing this testimony
in I know this Court has had to struggle
with this issue it's now my job to ask
the court to rule on it again now
the pictures I'll renew the objection
over the entrance of the pictures
counsel stood defense stipulated that
these pictures or that the stipulated of
the death the cause of death and where
these bodies were found these pictures
serve no probative value whatsoever as
far as how they were the bodies were
hidden hidden hiding the bodies would
have been after the fact of murder and
mr. killin was being charged with murder
whether they were hit or not would have
no value in this case at all
and the fact that we admit stipulated
that they were found in the earth and
damaged certainly survives to anybody
trying they start worn out in the open
and they were buried as such Your Honor
simply state that I'm asking the court
to for directed verdict at this time
based at the prior that this case is
almost solely been built on prior
testimony from a prior trial and there
has been no proper foundation laid to
allow this testimony in and I asked this
honorable court to give the defendant a
directed verdict to this time thank you
rade do not address elements that have
to be proven to the jury which would be
proper well proven element that will be
a proper in the most important verdict
this is simply a rehashing of
evidentiary issues that Lord has made
throughout this trial and so existence
does not have to address he'll be proven
for voluntary this in the courts
discretion as to whether or not we have
for example properly proven professor
it's Navigators facsimile service that
is a dependency of liability of that
effort then the court upholds month
versus court and making that decision is
what not Devon would rely on that is the
proof of the certification of the
trenders there again that's just an
evidentiary issues and for that
discretion to make that decision based
upon the certification and attachments
that have been marked for them
in this case for based upon that made
that decision that there was a trial I
spent on student respect Iowa's defense
lawyers in that trial that there was a
trial and was represented by counsel
they have had access to the certified
copy therefore they could have compared
them to the copies of the transcripts
that we provided defense counsel in
Discovery there was no objection that
there was being different one certified
copy and that their credential record so
unless there's some indication that
there was something to stay here to
change that copy there's no objection to
that bouncy changing the course of
brilliant
I think the transcripts itself
certification and for some judicial
notice will be compared with the trial
so a physician improvement bills of the
crown murder therefore
council has made the usual motion that
the defendants make at the conclusion of
the state's evidence that is for a
motion for directed verdict that motion
requires the court to rule on the
sufficiency of the evidence as a matter
of law causing the judge then to be the
Trier the facts of the case at this
point the law being that if the evidence
is proven to make it a prima facie case
considering the evidence as admitted has
been proved together with all reasonable
inferences flowing from that evidence
then I'm required to overrule that
motion in this case counsel does not to
contest the evidence that has been
presented by the state as being whether
or not it is sufficient to establish the
crime of murder therefore I'll not
address that father and that part of
your motion would be of course overruled
because that issue has not been raised
in your motion aside from that though
you did not address at this Court is of
the opinion that considering all of the
evidence that's been produced by the
court the state has met its burden now
with reference to the issues that you've
raised again regarding the failure of
the state to properly authenticate the
transcripts I've been very critical of
the state in this regard and that I do
not feel in our chastise them privately
about that that I thought that they just
did not develop that evidence as it
should have been developed and I'm quite
concerned with that yet being but beyond
that this Court has ruled on it though
they're being presented alpha dative
sand facts copies of death certificates
that this Court accepted the
parties presented two cases in support
of at least the state presented two
cases in support of his position that it
had met the authentication rule of an
unavailable witness by presenting
presenting a Tennessee case in a
Nebraska case and I think the Nebraska
case as I recall this presented was
majors versus state which held that that
was ruling on the authentication was a
collateral matter and was not an issue
of to be resolved as a matter of fact
therefore the court permitted the
transcripts to be presented to the jury
with reference to the photographs the
court has ruled on that you've already a
major record oh if it's in error you
preserved your record and this motion
did not establish anything addition to
that again I will restate that the rule
in Mississippi is that if photographs
can be even though prejudicial in and of
course all pictures of a person's body
is prejudicial if the court understands
that but if the probative value
overrides the prejudicial effect then
photographs are admissible that's
nothing unusual in this state and it's
usually discretionary with the judge if
he is of the opinion that it does have
probative value to be of assistance to
the jury who is the trial the facts of
the case in deciding whether or not a
crime has been committed and there is a
victim to that crime the photograph
Cento was introduced were the bodies of
the victims as they was removed from the
earth and damn the fact that it was the
bodies were buried is evidence of the
crime itself the intent the crime and
the intent to conceal the crime
the bodies were of course part of that
discovery and the jury can consider that
as to the intent of the crime that a
crime occurred somewhere else and was
buried elsewhere in the earthen dam as
an attempt to conceal that crime the
jury may consider that as evidence of
the intent of the defendants therefore
that are again your motion to exclude if
that's what your motion is is overruled
and the photographs again I would rule
or admissible photographs so your motion
for directed verdict mr. Moran is
overruled are you ready to proceed with
your testimony yes sir I'll give you
more time than that if you'd like mr.
Brent do you need more time
yes court will be in recess for 20
minutes
I'm aware that a lot of people believe
that there's nothing on a trial of a
case unless there's actual testimony
coming from the witness stand but I'll
assure you there's more than that and I
suppose if you believe it Court is slow
it kind of depends on which side of the
table you're sitting on if you're
defended in the case it may be moving
too fast we have been working on the
case and as I'm advised by mr. MacIntyre
he has four witnesses three witnesses
are here
one witness believed that he had been
released he's out of town when he's on
his way back here we're going to go
ahead now and take the testimony of the
three witnesses and then I'll make some
ruling on his announcement regarding the
availability of that witness so where
that gentleman will bring the jury back
into the courtroom and you call you
witness
match more are you calling Terry yes
come around please
there so then there'd be sworn by Miss
Lee you solemnly swear affirm that the
evidence you're about to give the court
in this case opinion shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth tell the court the jury your full
name please
Dorothy K Deering where do you live mr.
Deering maybe Union and what's your
address
Oh 206 for four highway 15 are you
married
I'm little okay Gary children one powder
all right how long have you been living
in Union Mississippi Oh
71 years I've been living where I live
now 40 about 45 years 45 years yes do
you know mr. Edgar a killing I did and
how do you know mr. Killa he's my oldest
brother all right
and has he been living in the community
there with you
45 years yes sir do you remember the
date of June 2 21st of 19 and 64 I did
now why do you remember that date
well because of all this and then it was
father today
and my mother always had us together oh
no you know Father's Day and my Mother's
Day and things huh your mother and
father yes nothing fun okay where did
they live lately up Jimbo house
communities underwear house crass
community on harm okay you go to church
that day yes
and after church a few got out of church
or where did you go we went to my
parents for dinner it was with you my
husband and daughter when you arrived at
your mother and father's home did you
see anyone else there beside your mother
and father yes I saw it gray and Lucille
and up my other brothers and my sister
we all got together and you saw your
brother had your rage killing me yeah I
saw it grade there what time did you
arrive at your parents home probably
after church you know I'm not too sure
but I think I went to church and then
went after church so it was probably
after 12 by 12 or 12 39 and y'all had
your Father's Day gathering there good
afternoon we did my DJ did y'all did you
take your lunch there oh they prepared
it yes huh it was your brother Edgar
a-killing there yes he balls
what time did y'all park company you and
Edgar ray killing it it was that
afternoon sometime probably around 4 or
5 okay and did you leave perfectly he
leave first you remember that I don't
remember for sure cuz we just said they
were eight in I had eight siblings seven
you know I was the eight and I don't
remember just when we left or what you
know but did you talk to Edgar a killing
yes sir and did you did he tell you
anything about having to go to other
meetings or anything that day no sir
okay therefore the question John Ross
you go
good morning miss dear my name is Jim
hood represent the state I got a few few
questions for you
did the defendant living in the home
where your parents lived do one does he
still live there he does and that's on
rock-cut Road is that what they call it
well um what would y'all come I don't
know I didn't call it I don't know but
there was a rock-cut Road but dog
well what did y'all call the road in
front of your your where your parents
live I don't know did you grow up there
at that on that home place yes I did I
was born there um in the County Road 550
noble idiots it's 559 oh yes and that's
about 810 miles south of Philadelphia on
highway 19 going to a greedy I'm sure he
is is that about right out of town ah
that's about um and how far off of
highway 19 do it's his home
it's your parents home we're still live
maybe a mile or two I know I'm not good
on miles so I don't know all right
um and that's you take a ride off 19 if
you were going south to hit fun right 59
he and his wife lived in the house there
with your parents right
if you gonna go on down to Meridian
about how far you think it would be to
go from from that house down to Meridian
but with 3035 miles to be about right I
have no idea okay how far on down
highway 19 is it from 5:15 about to
where you know where the intersection at
house is right there Posie store and all
that if you took a right to that road
that goes to Union another web being out
there for miles for something like that
probably I'm sorry but I don't know to
go from your father's home we all want
now I guess y'all want some reading when
you were kids and growing up so forth
you traveled to reading hang no sir not
much um be fair to say you can go down
to Meridian in 34 five minutes I think
phone you know where the long horn
restaurant was right down highway 20 and
and and in Meridian no sir I don't
you can't swear before this jury that
you know for certain that the defendant
was didn't leave at some point during
that that day can you I don't think he
did I sure don't I don't think so
thank you that's all we had on redirect
go back what you call it kid is killing
the Saudis where the testimony gave me
the whole truth nothing but truth God
and a little bit holes you have to
excuse them would you tell the court the
jury your full name please
Oscar's kid is killing and where do you
reside it's killing so where do you live
I live just up the road from aftereffect
array you're an address
yes sir on the speak ups of the court
reporter can take everything down you're
saying the jury can hear you also okay
I'm all that as a kid sir I'm hoarse
I'll talk as loud as a kid okay I'm
sorry
maybe you wanted my address yes sir
106 3l road 515 okay ma'am can you hear
me you numbers to Edgar Ray Kelly I've
known him since I am 74 year old now I'm
going to my up allowed or not ready to
him laughs Leah brothers his brothers do
you remember the date of June the 21st
yesterday I remember of 1964 that's said
okay now why do you remember that day
well we had a big reunion father's day
at my mother than dad's house and we met
that we having pretty often you know
heard you also remember because so
tragedy occurred on that day test I
heard that okay now did you what did you
do on Father's Day June 21st of 1964
well we just that my mother I always had
a big cookout you know this had a lot of
people lay eating and eating it go into
the piano and sang and deflect that you
know just a family reading was just a
family gathering for father's day test
all we had a mother and father day sheep
sheep leaden inviting people to come
meet were a lot of people there that day
or two you had several people that other
than the family yes okay what time did
you arrive at your mother and father's
home
I'll imagine nine o'clock in the morning
I'll deal just across the road most
people that Street four countries roads
roads all right and and when you when
you got there who did you see you at the
home of your mother and father well a
doctor you remember have a body x-ray
without all the time and my other
brothers I had five more brothers at
that time applause one of them you know
okay well they were all that did you see
your brother had a great killing there
when you arrived
yes that was he Artie that all he was
already there yes he lived that okay
then did the family had take the noon
meal on the date of Japan's prepare the
meal that day for the celebration of
Father's Day yes sad we just not eaten
about level clock me too left okay all
right what time did you leave that
evening I just roughly I'd say four or
five o'clock and did mr. killing that he
ever was he there at all times yesterday
did he ever discuss with you that he had
some meetings to make that day or
anything of that nature no sir he did
not
we had a good friend in the funeral home
that was mentioned mr. Petrich was in
the funeral home without a lot of his
dad it what funeral home were you
referring to
I think McClain Hayes I'm not sure I'm
sure I went up that but you know that
only some years ago okay
did your brother Edgar wake killing go
to the funeral home also yes sir
okay and you saw him there I seen him
now didn't a long but I was after a
while about what time was it that y'all
met at the funeral home I imagined it
was 7:00 8:00 o'clock okay and how long
do you remember how long you stay there
now side down the I don't hang around
too long I'll go and get out did you or
do you remember if you left first or
your brother there first I left first
okay and you don't remember what time
that was
no sir I don't that's all question I
have cross examine please the court
mr. killing you say this is Father's Day
in 1964 and y'all had a gathering at
your parents house is that right yeah
that's right who all was there but I can
name my lovin I just told the other
gentleman he was a lot of people that
imagine 50 60 people okay well you how
many other brothers do you have
I've got had five to ten one dad I
believe one from private before wouldn't
I mean at that time well I had a mild in
five Oh were they there also yes sir did
you have other sisters I've got two
sisters were they there also yes sir if
I understand your rights you say you
that you left the home place there about
four or five and Avenue that's right I
live just across roads that will allow
something I went through the house for a
while okay where was that Garre then he
was telling me at the home place there
okay and then you went to the funeral
home about 7:00 or 8:00 that night yeah
and understands right Edgar a went with
you no he didn't go with me went on his
own we got we got two different vehicles
you know we don't ride together all the
time did you go at the same time or no
we didn't go to the same town okay who
got there first I don't recollect what
he was in out ahead of me or I was and I
didn't go to see him I went to see Miss
Ted it rich and you got to the funeral
home about seven or eight o'clock yeah
you did yeah and you recall seeing Edgar
a there yeah but you don't know if you
got there first or he got there first no
no
mr. Kaelin did you know that Edgar a was
in the claim no sir I didn't even know
that I've heard more talking to your
daddy and granddaddy with you at plan
board I have him it's your house that's
honest I fall in the Bible gentlemen
that that's why I've heard it all these
years
so you didn't know effective Ray was in
or not I still don't know it was in it
he hadn't told me live until he tells me
I won't believe most all this stuff
y'all have it paid stuff I'd like to ask
you one questions you know give me sir
I'm sorry leave us all I have you on
anything else I'll redirect all right
I'm going to orally instruct the jury to
disregard the emotional statement of mr.
chinchilla now the court must recognize
that his brothers on trial and this is a
trying circumstance cause of his brother
so don't hold that against the defendant
in this case
Our Lady was where you raise your right
hand please sir you solemnly swear
affirm that the evidence you're about to
give the court in this case pending
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
all right mr. sharp would you tell court
and the jury your full name picture I'm
James commit shot and where do you live
mr. sharp
I live South Philadelphia about 10 miles
all right sir what did you give a
profession
I'm minister of retired minister
administer we're retired retired
minister and what was your last church
that you had I served as director
mission for this association for 21
years from 70 to 90 and for denomination
or you Baptist now in your how long did
you how long did you preach Reverend
well 12 i pastored churches 12 years
before that and I preached to all those
years as supplies and Bernard churches
ministers how long have you been
affiliated with the ministry since 5555
1955 to nurture I still do some ministry
that's 50 years ago there correct during
your tenure as a pastor and affiliation
with the Baptist Church have you ever
met a mr. Edgar ray killing yes I have
and what Association did you have with
him
we were friends neighbors ministers
together okay and did y'all pray
together yes sir Joe conduct services
together I don't believe we conducted
services at the same time together okay
do you know if he's an ordained Baptist
minister I understand that he is lost
now and how long have you known mr.
Killian
/ - all my life we were in high school
together
and since then we see each other
periodically and during that period of
time have you ever talked to other
people about mr. killin I very little
they talked to me a little bottom very
you've heard the talk in the community
about him yes I have his character yes
sir and based upon what you have learned
and observed from other people in the
community in which he lives and the
community which you live have you formed
an opinion as to his character yes I
have it is that character good or is it
bad
they're good thank you
excuse for the sharp I'm Jim hood I'm
represent the state I've got a couple
questions for you I'm a Baptist on how
good Baptist but I'm a battery so it'll
be too hard on you now do you know where
the where the defendant lives are weird
where he lives down here south - yes sir
you've been to his house yes sir what's
that road what was that road called
before they before the county switched
over to the number and system even
remember rock-cut Road that sound about
right
no sir plus it goes into the rock cut
road but it wasn't called rock cut room
you know what it was calm we we just
called it the killers room killing Road
yeah okay that it with that killing with
a G Orion I don't know
are you familiar with the existence of
the clan here in the Shelby County the
Ku Klux Klan just my words along not not
for me with you don't know who all was
in it or not know them okay um are you
familiar with the teachings of the Klan
what they believed no you know that they
based a lot of their beliefs on that you
shouldn't intermingle white and black
races I didn't know I don't know you
know that that's they say that the Bible
preaches about you shouldn't intermingle
the races you know where those
scriptures are not offhand do you
believe that as a Baptist
do you uh do you believe that the people
who murdered these young fellows in 1964
should pay for what they did I'm sorry I
didn't as understand don't you took the
men that were responsible for the
murders of these young men they should
pay for what they did shouldn't I let
the preacher answer that I think all sin
would answer in payment sir all sin will
answer in pavement some kind and our
laws though is as we're subject to
seizures laws as long as we're on this
earth all right so is it fair to say
that those who committed this crime
should be held responsible by the state
of Mississippi shouldn't I suppose so
and whomever organized this group of men
who committed this murder should also be
held responsible just witnessed those
who organized this killing he can answer
it if he does not he can say does not I
do not know so you don't know who who
knows responsible for green eyes in this
murder oh I do not
yeah we endorse mr. mo cheeks 1007 thank
you he called action
now have you heard from this witness's
on his white house that you've stayed to
me that you have a witness that's out of
town but his own route back here is he
here
was Mississippi and he turned around
he's back in roulette looks cubic
forever your last witness
through persistence not that
barbar
well I think those are mechanics and we
need to discuss out of presence of the
jury I'm all let the jury remain seated
you've been here let me hear this out of
the presence of the jury and I'll let
the will begin a wreck with a court
reporter
I think I'll hear it in a courtroom when
let the jury retire
are they about Helsing
mr. backett are do I are you asking for
resetting or continue to the case to
another day recess until at least Monday
morning bringing our two weeks
- remark with poor is that witness 40
common problem just just
let me ask you gentlemen this we have
yet to pass on jury instructions and
while we were in recess I reviewed those
instructions it won't take me long to
pass on them
I understand we'll have some objections
that you all will be making and we'll
have to go through that yet assuming
that that will take 30 minutes how much
time are you requesting for your closing
argument
mr. hood how much time are you
regretting this is so many facts so many
witnesses and I would say it'd take 40
minutes to and that's that's [ __ ] 4
million 44 marks would after hours so
we're ready talking about some hard
there two hours for closing all right
that's right an hour to have lunch is 10
almost 10:30 the testimony we're talking
about is short testimony well two
witnesses will say 30 minutes
we're looking at about three o'clock
something like that before the jury
could possibly receive a case if the
jury should not be unable to reach a
verdict in the court would be in a
position of trying to decide whether or
not to try to keep a mone into the knife
in deliberation or to recess MO until
Monday which I'm reluctant to do I'm not
going to keep them in deliberation on
Sunday are you mr. hood requesting that
we recess his case until Monday
assisting in that if we get up here get
our testimony on I don't think you're
supposed to take that long I like you to
the jury assassin yes you would but
you're not thinking about the jury and
jury could very easily be going into the
night and still be unable to reach a
verdict then the court would have the
problem of deciding whether to can
continue them until Monday or continue
with the deliberation on Sunday which
I'm very reluctant to this
well I'll tell you what I'm gonna do at
this time I'm going to recess this
hearing until we have some hearing from
you about the availability of these
witnesses I'd like to get that testimony
in here before lunch so I'm all be
instead by while you get on the phone
whatever you have to do mr. backett are
trying to get those two witnesses here
or being researched
now mr. McIntyre and mr. Moran they
state that one witness is unavailable to
the court at this time who could be here
later this afternoon and is on on route
from near the Alabama line up above
Columbus the second witness who is
rebuttal witness is unavailable because
if I've been unable to locate him so I
think I must in all fairness to all
parties give the part is the right time
to present that case knowing that I'm
causing an inconvenience to to everyone
the jury and all in course is judge
would like to get through to you know I
I've been here a while I've been here as
long as you have and I'm going I'm going
to recess this case and I'm going to
permit the jury and I have confidence in
the integrity of a person and I believe
it means that a person with knowing what
they can't do and can't do will follow
the direction of the court so I'm going
to direct the jury of what they should
do while they're in recess and I'm going
to let them enjoy an opportunity to be
with their parents or their children be
with them and I think that's only decent
and that's what out it bring in the jury
mr. Mitchell do you get all that down
that's all right dear I can't repeat it
the ladies and gentlemen we're at the
close of a trial of a case and if the
case has been smooth in progressing
rather rapidly so far it's not unusual
when we get on to the very end of a case
to start running into the rough edges of
it
now I've tried to smooth it out as best
as we can we do have problems which
we're not going to be able to face the
case today this Court is very concerned
about trying to finish the case today
getting on into the afternoon way over
perhaps before the case could be
delivered to you we have the testimony
we think of two remaining witnesses then
we go through the process of
deliberating and arguments of the
attorneys instructions to you on the law
and then for your deliberation and
you're entitled to take as much time as
you need to deliberate upon the facts
and the issues of this case and the law
of this case will the law that I'll give
you and I'm thinking that perhaps if I
do that that we would get on into the
evening hours and you would not have
reached a fair decision in this case
you're entitled to your own opinion as
to the outcome of this case that's your
decision and and I should give you as
much time as you need I should give
these parties without ample time to
direct their case to it
I realize that each and all of you and I
observed yesterday when I announced to
you that by agreement of the state and
the defendant that you would not be
sequestered to be permitted to go home
for your father's days and I recognize
the relief that you already had because
of that announcement because I think
it's what you wanted to do I trust you
and I want you to believe in me at this
time I'm going to look at each and every
one up and I'm going to ask of you will
you follow the courts instructions while
you're in
says if if I allow you to go home and
miss Covington will you do that you tell
me you do that and Miss Marron would you
follow my instructions to the nth degree
and mr. Sabel and mrs. Griffin and mrs.
Smith will you follow my instructions
will you do that would you say and would
you ma'am would you follow my
instructions mr. Miller
will you follow my instructions miss
bond with you and mr. Lyon would you
fall of course instructions that Rock
have rocky I will get him before we get
through here would you follow my
instructions and miss moody in this
Clark mr. Piner and mr. Purdy and miss
Wilson and Miss Moore and my structures
will be this to you as such you'll not
watch a newscast regarding this case law
17 no you tell me that you're not
watching this it should develop through
television that you'll turn it off
you'll not listen to it you'll not watch
it all 17 of you now you're not read a
news account of this case and more
important than that you'll not go home
and discuss this with your families your
husband your wife your friends or anyone
else all 17 of you promise me you won't
do it and I say this too you're the ones
that's on the jury I mean it's your
decision you have that responsibility
and no one else you ever impose their
thoughts upon you they should not tell
you what to do that should be your right
to make that decision not theirs and one
more thing if anyone should contact you
attempt to talk to you about this case
attempt to talk to you to tell you how
to decide this case we'll all 17 of you
when we return here promise me that
you'll give me that person's name and
tell me what that person had to say and
I'll assure you that will be the last
time that person will do that because
I'll personally
handle that man we all uh get follow my
instructions you're to report to the to
the detention center at eight o'clock
Monday morning they you will be escorted
then to the courthouse and will continue
with the case now you have notebooks
there I want you to put place your name
upon the face of that notebook each of
you write your name on the notebook
the clerk will come around and she'll
take possession of those those books and
they'll be returned to you Monday
morning
now mr. hood mr. Duncan are you
satisfied with the court's instructions
you suggest additional instructions mr.
McIntyre mr. Moran are you satisfied
with the court's instructions do you
suggest an additional instruction
I'm not sure where I made it clear or
not you're not to discuss this at all
with your family members just stay away
from the conversation at all just
telling that you're under oath you have
a duty to perform and you cannot discuss
it you gonna make the decision yourself
all right that's your husband your
families your children or who else we do
that now you gentlemen town s'you you're
not going to be recessed I'm on meet
with you in chambers at this time and we
go and pass on your instructions we have
that out of the way for Monday morning I
hope you enjoy your weekend I'll let you
pass
the court will now be in recess until
8:30 Monday morning and likewise I hope
you have a pleasant weekend you're
watching c-span 3 history looking at
people in a